I really want to start with a sincere
congrats on the series uh I thought you
guys were both so fantastic and Sean
does not suck as a director thank you no
he's he's he's pretty good he's all
right right exactly let's not let the
ego get too much bigger for him yeah
so I am curious though you know you
never know how people are going to react
to something uh and so this has been the
number one thing on Netflix for I think
two weeks now what is that like for you
guys after putting in such hard work to
bring this to life I guess it's always a
little overwhelming I mean when when you
so Co when you do something you put so
much work into it and you pour your
heart and your soul into it and um you
just hope for the best outcome and you
hope for for many as many people as
possible being touched and and connected
to the story when it actually happens
it's um yeah it it's it's just really
rewarding and beautiful beautiful it's
an honor for us to be able to like to
spend so much time making something that
people can watch in their free time and
they could do anything with their free
time and they chose to like spend it
with something we we made it was it's
just it feels um maybe a little unreal
maybe maybe it's maybe it's not true
maybe this is all giant hoax I don't
know but it's spectacular it's so cool
when you were looking when you realized
what the shoot was going to entail and
what you were going to be doing what was
the day that you had circled in terms of
I'm really nervous to film this or I'm
really
excited that's a good question that's a
very good question I have I have okay so
the one scene that I was
absolutely terrified to do Mark and I
had this in common was the scene where
Daniel says goodbye to
Marie we we were just dreading that
scene oh my God and it's not like in
comparison to the rest of the show it's
it's not that much of an exertion of
emotion but it was just so hard on both
of us I think so like that was um that
was what I was dreading the most and the
one that I was looking forward to the
most was the the the dunking with with
ls yeah just so funny that that's the
the scene you were looking forward to
the most I know that's my safe space is
apparently torture scenes I don't know
no my safe space is um is like physical
stuff because I like come from a dance
background a martial arts background so
like that was something like I could
latch on to and be like heck yes I can
do this I might not know how this acting
thing works and the set thing works yet
but I can I can do that and it was it's
really funny cuz um that was what
shocked a lot of people it wasn't just
you yeah like that's the thing you take
comfort in weirdo oh my God I remember
on my birthday sorry real quick on my
birthday um um you know Joshy the F the
the yeah the he collected videos from
the whole team and the cast to send to
me for my birthday which is really
lovely and your video was from The
Grotto yeah and you had the best time
but you still had the best time and you
looked so alive yeah I know and like you
build up these tears and it's like not
natural just shut them down so I was
like still crying did Louis's Happy
Birthday song or whatever it was I'm
like in tears like bouncing up and down
like a little kid and there was like a
unicorn floaty going by cuz the crew
surprised me at the end of that sequence
with a unicorn floaty it's really great
wait you didn't share which scene for
you that's true my I think my the scene
I was looking forward to the most was
the one with Schmidt where where Vanna
tells his story because it's um most of
most of the character is quite reacting
and quite passive I suppose and I just
loved him getting active taking the lead
in a scene and and being able to share
the story um and that was something I
thoroughly thoroughly
enjoyed and you you really pumped up
your scene with Hugh too you were so
excited for that leading up to it that's
true yeah that's true I love Hugh he's
so sweet and scared I don't I don't know
I mean I to be fair Sean and the whole
team and the whole cast everyone
everyone was so incredibly welcoming and
um and we could have felt a huge amount
of pressure and funny enough it was it
was just a big blast every day to be on
set even though the topic was dark um
even though it was a heavy material but
it was we had I had such a good time on
it yeah we all enjoyed it and I think it
shows I'm curious for now fans of this
series what do you think they would be
surprised to learn about the making of
the show the amount of dad jokes that
Mark Ruffalo and I between takes yeah
like embarrassing really bad jokes that
nobody laughed at but we were hysterical
over um they'd be shocked about that
yeah and the whole I the whole cast was
sort of mocking Hugh and his
accent my name is H and tonight I'm
going to tell you all the things all the
beautiful things in life professor and
you boy must be
Fearless yes we we H knows we do this
it's okay yeah but that was an ongoing
joke and the amount of times we weren't
actually together in scenes so like
episode 4 lars's coverage my coverage
and Louis's coverage was all done on
different days and so the crew would do
our voices for whoever was on screen oh
yeah so that was really funny there
should be a blooper real of that
somewhere of Sean being like it's fun
Maria I'm here to rescue you it was
great Sean did great did a good Verner
uh yeah again we need to not inflate
that ego it's very important you know uh
ve very very important so I'm sure you
guys were familiar with the book uh was
there anything in the book that you
really felt like this has to be in the
series or are really happy that it was
in the series you know what I mean oh
gosh I I think what what I was really
excited about uh because it's so visual
is that opening scene in the book where
the leaflets come down for Marie and
she's she goes to the window she feels
the leaflet she can feel the imprint um
the Pressed paper she knows something is
written on it but she can't see it um
and her fingers aren't sensitive enough
to to actually read it with her fingers
so she she doesn't know what it says but
she knows something dangerous is
happening and that was such a vivid
scene in the book um and it literally
gets brought to life on screen exactly
as it's written so I was really excited
about that and one scene that we didn't
do that I was actually really I was
hopeful that we would do but never was
in the script is a scene between Marie
and ettien where ettien is reading to
her from The Voyage of the beagle and
they're like crafting this little
fictional universe together and they're
playing make believe and it gets ettien
out of a shell um and then they like put
on Baldi and they just have a little a
jam and dance session together and it's
like eten breaking out of his out of his
oyster shell and I sad that didn't make
it to screen but I can I can see why cu
the series is so tight and action-packed
I see why it didn't make it but that was
a scene I really liked in the book we
actually shot one scene with Fred which
might be news to some of the fans of the
show um and he was fantastic as well
yeah yeah and it didn't it didn't make
it um into the cut which which was a
little sad but I'm sure there were
plenty of good reasons again Sean knows
what he's doing
um
don't tell him he's good um but that was
that was something that I was really
excited about when we shot it and then
was a little sad about that storyline is
really yeah yeah all I definitely have
to ask you about being cast because Sean
you know again speaking about Sean he
posted a video of you you know reacting
to getting cast and it's pretty crazy
that you got this role so at what point
did you like did you ever think in the
auditioning process that you had it
chance or was this just sort of like a
test run for the future funny story had
no idea I was having a really rotten
week and in many ways a really rotten
Year my mental health was completely
tanked um I fought my whole life to get
access to an education and I had finally
finally made it um and at the same time
I was like I was just really grateful to
be there but I wasn't happy and I didn't
know why and I literally went on the
audition because I was
having a bad day and someone told about
it and I was like you know if you're
having a bad day just read from your
favorite book it'll it'll maybe this
will be a fun thing I didn't have any
friends where I was I had just moved and
so I literally recorded Mark's lines on
my iPad leaving space in between for me
to do Marie's lines and then got on
camera did the Marie lines and just sent
my first take to the casting people and
I didn't think anyone would ever see it
and then like a day later I got called
back um and then I kept getting called
back and then I was like oh boy I should
tell my mother and I was like you told I
had told my mother until I met with
Shawn for the first time and that's what
I'm like I should probably tell her cuz
it was like one of her favorite books
ridiculous never once thought actually
had like planned a speech with my mom
thanking them for doing an authentic
casting search hoping that they'd still
hire someone who was blind or low vision
and asking if they thought I was good
enough to um audition for Community
Theater never gave the
speech I don't know what happened and
now now 3 million 300 million people
have access to my audition tape
apparently according to Sean's
statistics so um and SE never lies crazy
yeah when it comes to statistic 300
million people will have access to why
is he transatlantic I don't know 300
million people will have access to your
audition tape um I don't know where he
got that one but that's what he told me
like a year ago and I'm like now uh it's
out in the world and it's really crazy
to see how raw it is and how I was like
like at the beginning of of that journey
and found the career I always wanted and
didn't know that I needed and it just it
makes me so happy it's the first time in
my life I've like universally been been
happy it's wild I don't even know that's
amazing so cool I am really super happy
for you sincerely and as I said at the
beginning you guys are both fantastic in
this and it's a huge hit so I don't have
to say wish you well thank you so much
for giving me your time of course thank
you so much have a good day